the sentencing hearing for Army sergeant
Bowe Bergdahl resumes today after
emotional testimony Bergdahl walked away
from his post in Afghanistan and was
captured by the Taliban after five years
he was released in a prisoner exchange
Bergdahl pleaded guilty to desertion and
misbehavior before the enemy he says
that he left his post to report
misconduct at his base mark Strassmann
is at Fort Bragg North Carolina with the
evidence presented against him mark good
morning good morning in Bergdahl's case
that charge of misbehavior before the
enemy has to do with the way he put US
soldiers at risk when they went to look
for him no US soldier was killed in that
search but the court did hear from a
former Navy SEAL who was wounded Bowe
Bergdahl arrived at the Fort Bragg
courthouse where he came face to face
with men who went on dangerous rescue
missions to find him
army colonel Clinton Baker who commanded
Bergdahl's battalion at the time
testified one unit was on patrol for 37
days straight the only time you slept
was when you couldn't stay conscious
anymore he testified retired Navy SEAL
James hatch walks with a limp and a
service dog now but in 2009 he was part
of Bergdahl's rescue mission near the
Pakistan border he was shot in the leg
during that mission on the stand he
described the moments following his
injury it hurt really bad I thought it
was dead he survived but his military
career was over I felt like you know
maybe if I'd have done things a little
bit differently not gotten hurt
you know the mission wouldn't have
failed you know in 2015 hatch talked
about his injury and Bergdahl he needs
to know you know how much was risk the
judge is considering a motion to drop
the case over President Trump's comments
on Bergdahl on the campaign trail then
candidate Trump called him a traitor who
should be shot you know the old days
boom firing squad not so the judge ruled
in February that he has not been
influenced by President Trump adding
those comments were made when the
president was still a civilian candidate
but defense lawyers argued Trump brought
his campaign comments to the forefront
again last week I'm not gonna comment on
him but I think people have heard my
comments in the past
armie evaluators concluded that Bergdahl
suffered from a schizotypal personality
disorder when he walked off his post in
Afghanistan his lawyers want the judge
to consider that as he decides whether
to put Bergdahl behind bars for as long
as the rest of his life Nora Marc thank
you